لقد مررت به الآن يقولون إنني
محصن ويمكنني أن أشعر أنني قوي للغاية
وسأدخل في هذا المفهوم الخاطئ للجمهور
رقم واحد
بمجرد أن تحصل على الطمع 19 ، فأنت محصن إلى الأبد
وقد أظهرت إحدى الدراسات أن
الأجسام المضادة المعادلة يتم إنتاجها على الأقل
بعد خمسة أشهر من إصابة شخص ما ،
لكننا لا نعرف فقط كيف يترجم ذلك
إلى المدة التي سيتم فيها حماية شخص ما أو
تحصينه بعد الإصابة ،
بدأنا نرى عددًا من الحالات
التي يتم الإبلاغ عنها
لأشخاص أصيبوا مرة أخرى بالعدوى بشكل جيد  - حالات موثقة
لأشخاص أصيبوا بالعدوى بعد
فترة وجيزة نسبيًا ،
لذلك عليك حقًا أن تكون حريصًا
على عدم الاقتباس تمامًا من
سوء الفهم المناعي 2
يجب أن نحاول التخفيف من هذا الفيروس من خلال
تحقيق مناعة القطيع بشكل طبيعي ،
ومن المهم أن يفهم الناس
العلم الطبي لمعرفة أن
المناعة البشرية الطبيعية للسكان ،
يطلق عليها أحيانًا
مناعة القطيع ، من المهم جدًا أن
تتطور هذه هي الطريقة التي يتم بها القضاء على الفيروسات.
وضح شيئًا ما ، فإن مناعة القطيع
ليست بالضرورة شيئًا سيئًا ،
إنها مجرد مسألة كيفية الوصول إلى
هناك بطريقة واحدة هي لقاح
يأمل الكثير من الناس في الحصول عليه ، لكن
ما يبدو أن أطلس دكتور سكوت
يصفه
هو ترك العدوى
مجانية والآن هذا  اكتسبت الفكرة مزيدًا من
الجاذبية مع الإعلان المثير للجدل الذي
كتبه بعض العلماء الذين يبدو
أنهم يشجعون أولئك الذين ليسوا
عرضة للمضي قدمًا والتعرض
لـ Covet 19
لاستئناف الحياة الطبيعية من أجل الوصول إلى
مناعة القطيع
غالبية أمتنا أكثر من 90
النسبة المئوية من السكان لا يزالون
عرضة للإصابة ،
ما يتحدث عنه مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض الدكتور روبرت ريدفيلد
هو دراسة تظهر أن
أقل من 10 من الأشخاص في
الولايات المتحدة قد أصيبوا بالعدوى على الأرجح
، وعليك أن تضع في اعتبارك تحقيق
مناعة القطيع التي يجب أن يكون هذا الرقم
حوالي ستين.  إلى سبعين في المائة من
السكان الذين
يفكرون الآن في أن أكثر من مائتين
وسبعة عشر ألف شخص
ماتوا بالفعل من مطمع 19 مع
عشرة في المائة مصابون
انظروا إلى ما يمكن أن تعنيه العدوى بنسبة ستين في المائة ،
حسب تقديرات ihme ، فإن هذا قد
يعني
أكثر من 1.2 مليون حالة وفاة ، إنها
فكرة خاطئة من الناحية العلمية والأخلاقية.
ليس 200000
في الثاني من فبراير ، بدأت إدارة ترامب
في تنفيذ قيود السفر
من قيود البر الرئيسي للصين
ولكن ليس حظرًا كاملًا
لأن المواطنين الأمريكيين والمقيمين الدائمين
لا يزالون قادرين على السفر
إلى البلاد من حظر السفر في الصين
يمكن أن يمنع هذه
العدوى في بلد ما ولكن  ليس إذا
تم وضعها فقط
للأشخاص الذين يسافرون
كمواطنين من الدول الأجنبية
في تحليل أجراه مركز السيطرة على الأمراض وجد أن
القيود المفروضة على السفر من أوروبا
جاءت بعد فوات الأوان لأنه بحلول الخامس عشر من مارس
كان هناك بالفعل
عدوى واسعة النطاق في مدينة نيويورك
في وقت مبكر
من بؤرة تفشي المرض في الولايات المتحدة في ذلك الوقت كان لدينا
f
أكثر من 100 حالة وفاة الآن لدينا أكثر من
مائتي ألف